welcome our colleague Cornelia Ernst
co-chairing this meeting in her capacity
as chair of the Iran delegation
many thanks also to Hannah Norman who
was an inspiration for the activities of
this week indeed you will have seen
already that the European Parliament
that our institutions our subcommittee
our delegation effort and other
institutions have foreseen
solidarity days with Iranian people in
this week and that for good reason we
will have several events today tomorrow
and on Thursday the objective is to
explore with a large spectrum of
Representatives of Iranian Civil Society
ways of supporting human rights women
and Civil Society in Iran and to reflect
on the prospects of Iran's Democratic
movement and on how the EU should
respond to the challenges Iran faces in
these days
since September 22 and the tragic death
of young Iranian women Masha amini
Iranian peaceful protesters were faced
with massive repression by the Iranian
authorities the European Parliament in
our subcommittee especially have
followed closely the developments
in the country with hope and with
concern the European Parliament adopted
several resolutions
allow me to recall them briefly October
22 European Parliament condemned the
systematic violent arrests abuses and
ill-treatment of women as well as the
widespread intentional
use of force by Iranian Security Forces
against peaceful protesters January 23
we condemned the executions of young
protesters and the killings of several
hundreds of peaceful protesters and in
this resolution also we called on the
high representative and the council to
expand the necessarily to expand the EU
sanction list to all individuals and
entities responsible for human rights
violations
and last March finally we condemned the
poisoning of thousands of school girls
and called on the commission and the
member states to increase Technical and
capacity support to Iranian Civil
Society we urged member states to
facilitate the issuance of visas and
Asylum and emergency grants to those who
need to leave Iran particularly women
and girls
today in the presence of our
distinguished guests we wish to go a
step further we would like to have an
assessment of the situation
in Iran and in particular in the areas
our guests are working on
and we would discuss concrete
recommendations what we can consider
what we the European Parliament would be
the European Union and our member states
can do to concretely constructively and
efficiently help
to shape and to build a better future
for Iranians this is our
purpose today I could finally inform you
that we will continue to actively
address the situation in Iran including
this week in Geneva available as a
subcommittee conductor visit and meet
with the members of the independent
International
fact-finding Mission decided in November
22 by the U.N Human Rights Council by
the special rapporteur on the situation
of human rights in Iran and additionally
key stakeholders we will share the
outcome of today's debate with all of
them and explore new avenues to reflect
and to cooperate I now give the floor to
Cornelia announced the chair of the
delegation for relations with Iran
thanks a lot I will speak in my home
language a wonderful German language
um
first of all thank you very much
to our guests
it's a great pleasure to have you with
us here today I'd also like to thank Udo
Bullman
who is leading the human rights
committee for the excellent cooperation
that we have it's very important that we
speak with one voice as a parliament
that we remain consistent and coherent
and that we'll pull in the same
direction
uh Alfred and human rights committees
are working very closely together and
it's not doesn't always go without
saying that we get such good cooperation
since the violent death of uh MS amini
we've been looking at the question of
democracy and human rights in Iran
there have been many
times
many resolutions as we've just heard I
mean we worked have been working on this
in fact since 2011 when there were big
demonstrations there in
2012 We There were the Sakura of price
was given to uh to activists from Iran
and I had met both of them in Tehran
after they were awarded the prize which
was very moving moment for me
is doing
enormously important work to support
women and women's rights
and she's paying a very high price for
that as we all know uh and that goes for
many activists in Iran who are still
there still active and they are paying a
high price for their activities
and we need to be stand uh firm by their
sides
the protests of the last few months are
not the first ones in the Islamic
Republic but in terms of their quality
uh the there is a different mood and the
uh
uh gap between the activists and the
people in the State uh has become bigger
and bigger
this conflict how we can overcome this
conflict is something that we need to
reflect on we've been through similar
cases in uh Europe I come from a country
where we had a peaceful resolution a
long and successful Revolution and it's
important because if
every historical situation is unique but
we need to draw lessons from each one
and we need to aim at being peaceful
inclusive and Democratic in our approach
we in the European Parliament
want to support Civil Society
and that is something that we've been
doing for many many years now and I
think there are a few parliaments that
are as present with civil side by side
with civil society and those in the
Iranian diaspora know that we all want
change in that country the sanctions in
the USA aren't making things uh making
it easy to help financially we are
trying to help Civil Society in Iran uh
nevertheless and
in Europe should not uh push back people
who come to Europe from Iran uh asking
for a refugee uh protection
and we really
must not uh let any aspect of drop any
aspect of all of this situation we need
to focus on every uh everything every
point so this discussion is all the more
important thank you very much thank you
Cornelio I'll give the flood to madikov
journalist and women's rights activist
for some seven minutes please
hello everybody thank you for inviting
me and my friend to talking about my
country
my lovely country under the dictatorship
government and about the modern
revolution in Middle East women life
freedom women like Freedom Revolution
can change not just the Iran can change
many things in Middle East and in the
world about Islam about the dictatorship
about the how women can make a decision
about everything from their dress their
clothes until their country change their
country
uh this revolution started just less
than one month after Islamic revolution
you know the first group of people who
make a demonstration against Islamic
regime was women in the 8th of March
just three weeks after overcome the
Islamic regime in Iran
so I think we now can believe that the
women in Iran start to change mola
regime and Islamic regime
and thank you for this opportunity to
talk about
and this revolution I will briefly
mention some important issue
the most important thing it's the
internet in my country
all kind of social media in Iran is
filtered
telegram Instagram
uh WhatsApp
Netflix
YouTube Facebook Twitter and all kinds
of social social media can you imagine
so it's uh the government try to make a
wall between Iran and out of Iran
and I think one of things that the
European country and western country can
help to activists inside Iran to make
their voice is try to help to Freedom
internet access to the international
internet is essential for Iran over the
past 10 years Iranian governments has
developed its own computer networks
known as a national Information Network
as an alternative to internet every time
that the Iranian government shut down
the internet the local network is
working if we want to break this network
we need to provide access to the
international internet such as clothes
providers
the United States government issued
General license D2 to relax take
sanction however we are not seeing any
of these big technology companies
actually implements it it's not only
access it's also about security people
in Iran need to restore their data
outside of Iran to predict their data
from unlawful access of Iranian security
service
EU also needs to keep
accountable those who violence right of
Iranian people to access to the internet
targeted individual sanction can help
for example
in blood in November the government shut
down internet for five days and killed
more than one thousand people in the
street it's between one thousand or one
thousand five hundred and after more
than two weeks we as a journalists can
understand how was happening in our
country
and now every time that the internet is
weaker and weaker in Iran the first
thing that come in our mind it's what's
happening they start to kill others they
start to arrested our friends
and journalists and feminists and that's
why I think inside everything else that
the Western Country can help the most
important thing is the technology and
the internet
so we need to break the isolation but
relax and take sanction and at the same
time going after those who are
responsible for violence of Human Rights
I I highly request that you uh as the
the Iran government to let you visit the
Iran prisons especially even prison I
could not bear the prison so I was
forced to flee the country but I'm
really too I'm really ready to accompany
the visiting team to visit the prison in
the future
if the Islamic Republic access nuclear
weapons
it will threaten the word today Iranian
people fight for word peace supporting
the current revolution in Iran is not
just make benefit the Iranian people but
it could secure benefits all over the
world the Iran governments support all
Islamic extremist group in the world
their weapons and the budget come from
the Iran's oil money Middle East widow
without an Islamic Republic could be
calmer and more peaceful from this
from the Syrian War Yemen and Sudan and
providing weapons for okrine's war to
assaulting Salma rushti to become of
Islamic regime in Iran
negotiation with the with a government
that kills its own people is exalting to
most Iranian people who do not want this
government
Western countries are considered about
making another Syria or Libya but it's
because they don't know this modern
Revolution where
more than 90 of Iranian 90 percent of
Iranian people are educated the highest
education education rates in Middle East
Iranian people want freedom and
democracy which is why they are against
Islamic dictatorship
Iranians have the most Asylum Seeker
among among the asylums who try to cross
Munch kennel
the continuation of the current Islamic
regime could even increase the rate of
Asylum Seeker
so I just I asked you uh listen to the
independent uh
journalists and activists and try to
help to the people in Iran just as they
want
not something that you can think it's
good for yourself or your country what
is good for Freedom human rights and
women rights in Iran thank you
foreign
[Applause]
many many thanks for your analytical
approach but also for the very very
precise recommendations what is to be
done this is exactly what we would like
to see today and what we like to discuss
amongst us to go further in in progress
in giving support Hamad ismailian is
with us I had the pleasure to meet him
in a huge manifestation in Frankfurt
where he contributed to
um he is a writer and activist and I
have to say that we are deeply sorry
for the loss that he has
um to pay to the crimes of the regime
and because members of his family fall
uh fell victim to this criminal
activities uh we welcome you here and we
are very happy to have you today with us
amen
thank you very much Mr Bowman
um distinguished members thank you for
inviting me to appear before you
my name is Hamid ismailian I lost my
wife a nine-year-old daughter when the
Islamic revolutionary guard Corps
shut down Ukrainian flight ps752 over
the Skies of Tehran on January 8 2020.
I've been active with that Association
of families of flight ps75 to victims in
their fight for justice truths and
accountability
that heinous crime claimed the lives of
177 innocent passengers and crew members
aboard the board that fly including 55
Canadians
and many European passengers from
Ukraine Sweden and United Kingdom
the willful murder of flight ps752
passengers is yet another link
in the endless chain of crimes
perpetrated by the Islamic Republic
regime over the last 44 years
I join you today to speak of the
continuing of paywall that has involved
Iran since the murder of massagino amini
seven months ago it is indeed a great
honor to be in Europe where so many of
you have stood with the people of Iran
in their Quest For Justice human rights
and Liberty many European elected
officials have stepped up to sponsor
persecuted Iranian dissidents I would
also like to thank many of your member
states for ensuring that the Human
Rights Council in Geneva created a
fact-finding mission on human rights
violations in Iran and for supporting
the initiative to expel the Islamic
Republic from the U.N committee and the
status of women in New York
we know all too well that under these
dire circumstances time and advocacy is
essential
United in diversity is the motto that
underlines the essence of the European
Union that the strive strives to forge a
common Destiny rooted in shared values
and a humanist Heritage unity and
diversity inspires the woman life
Freedom revolution in Iran that is led
by Brave women and Youth
Europe through the Awakening in the
aftermath of Putin's aggression teaches
us that authoritarian states do not
respect these fundamental values and
cannot be trusted and I certainly hope
that you will know now ensure that your
policies regarding the Islamic Republic
of Iran demonstrate the same strong
commitment to your core principles and
values the dire situation in Iran
continues Iranian women continued their
decades-long resistance against
repression forced a job and an apartheid
system that suppresses them in all
aspects of their lives
we look blue color workers around the
country suffer under corrupt system that
leaves them with little to no means of
sustenance the sporadic strikes are
evolving into a nationwide workers
uprising
white color workers suffer under similar
circumstances and must soon Join the
Revolution with institutional strikes
young men and women have no means to
communication with the outside world as
a state control system censors monitors
and limits access to the internet
tragically young school girls are
systematically targeted in their schools
with widespread poison attacks these are
merely the highlights of the conditions
in Iran several hundred deaths many
summary executions after rapid show
trials prominent political dissonance
and social activists are in prisons
around the country and many more
thousand ordinary peaceful protesters
have been incarcerated with no access to
proper legal representation
rampant inflation and exponential
devaluation of currency has left the
general population in equity in acute
despair all the while the military
kleptocracy and regime operatives enjoy
lavish lives and use their privileged
position to loot the country's coffers
Iranians are demanding nothing less than
an end to the unaccountable criminal
treaty in Tehran
any attempts so and with Paul
suggestions more than 80 percent of the
population wants an end to the regime as
such any attempt to appease the regime
will prove a fully of historic
proportions it is time for Europe to
awaken to the fact that the Islamic
Republic is not just a menace to its own
people but that is equally beholden to
undermining Global Security and even the
welfare of you EU citizens as your
average Iranian regime has assassinated
many of its opponents in Europe Belgium
recently convicted an operative of the
regime that sought to denote a bomb at
the crowded event British officials
recently dismantled as many as as 10
such attempts on their soul Germany
uncovered an individual allegedly
directed by the irgc to plan a chemical
attack in the country the Islamic regime
has wronged fully convicted and is shame
and incarcerated for innocent sweets to
French one German and and one Austrian
national in Shameless hostage diplomacy
any attempt by the EU EU to undertake
renewed negotiations with the Islamic
Republic will simply be construed as a
sign of weakness and further embolden
the regime to continue on the same
audacious past
I'm here to put your ears to the hearts
of Brave Young Iranian men and women and
compel you to take action
use your voice to force Islamic regime
to stop the Bloodshed on the streets
free all political prisoners immediately
and without conditions or the
humiliation of pale or suspended
sentences demand that the Islamic regime
halt all executions immediately expel
the Islamic Republic from International
workers unions the Iko and other
International organizations
help us to coordinate with International
workers unions to set up a strike fund
for Iranian workers use the technology
and means at your disposal to provide
free and unhindered access to the
internet for the people of Iran and
finally call the irgc what it is an
officially named at nefarious
bloodthirsty and corrupt entity as a
terrorist organization
put your words into action and prove
your solidarity with the people of Iran
by dismissing Iranian diplomas from your
countries and listing the Islamic
revolutionary guard core personal as
personal nagrata in the ueu I thank you
for the time you provided me for my
opening remarks and I look forward to
answering any questions you may have
thank you very much thanks very much
Ahmed
our next speaker is Fatima Karimi
researcher in sociology of gender
women's rights activist and president of
Kurdistan human rights Network in France
please you have to follow for seven
minutes
yeah
ladies and gentlemen
I'm here today as a representative of
the Kurdistan human rights Network and I
thank you for the opportunity to speak
most of the Iranian people is oppressed
by the central authorities
that and initially by the pallavi
Dynasty and now by the Islamic Republic
but the level of Oppression is not the
same depending on sexual sexual
orientation uh religious beliefs and so
forth the oppression is more or less
strong the Kurds are one of the most
oppressed group in Iran
because the Kurdish question is
according to the Iranian authorities a
danger
to the country
these oppressive policies uh way very
heavily on the Kurds and
have historically
and the uh
death of Gina hermini is one such
example
there are still no clear statistics on
the number of Kurds killed since the
1980s but we know that thousands died in
the bombardments and in prison
at least
90 Kurdish women were executed over this
period in the various prisons of the
country
a United Nations reporter
uh states that almost half of the
political prisons in the country are
Kurds according to the Kurdistan human
rights network
of 82
uh people uh executed by the uh Islamic
regime for were executed for political
reasons
president admini Assisi was executed
because of B belong to the Democratic
movement in the country
the Kurds
have played a very important role in the
recent events and they've paid a very
heavy heavy price for their uh in
evolvement uh 100 over 100 were killed
including 11 children and also have also
been many arrests the Iranian regime
has
blocked internet access
in order to fight against the
demonstrators
and as the figures show the oppression
levels of Oppression are higher very
high in the Kurdish reasons but this
hasn't
um cost the regime very dearly because
the focus of
the various organizations both Iranian
and international was mainly on the
central regions of the country rather
than On the Border regions of the
country and the propaganda of Terror run
accusing the Kurds of being separatists
works very well even with part of the
opposition movement
so the Kurds are often marginalized on
the pretext that they are separatists
ladies and gentlemen members of the
European Parliament human rights in the
Kurdish areas are reaching a critical
point and these regions require
particular attention as a result we need
to take into account the diversity of
Iranian society and to adopt effective
measures against the uh regime
and the violations of human rights do
not sacrifice human rights issues when
negotiating with this oppressive regime
and I thank you for your attention
[Applause]
thank you so much Fatima our last guest
who is going to address us is
the senior advisor to presidential
candidate Mr mirjose in musabi you have
to flaw for seven minutes
foreign
good morning thank you for your
invitation I'm here as a lawyer
I'm a law professor and for 20
years as part of the shared Squadron and
I'm here as a lawyer today
I will share some of my views with you
in legal terms we have a massive and
systematic violation of human rights in
Iran
this is not only about civil and
political rights but also economic
social and cultural rights and
environmental law is also being violated
there are many different causes behind
this but the main course is the absence
of a state uh state of Law and
corruption which is a structural aspect
of the earth government which plays into
their hands and
of criminal organizations in and
involving them in the legal government
of the country and we are against legal
sanctions which reinforce the hegemony
of these criminals and weakens uh the
population and Civil Society
to remediate the lack of the rule of law
at least formally
we have for a long time called for
the application
of the Constitution as it stands in
spite of the weaknesses that exist in
the text
the Iranian Societies in a state of
transition at the moment and it is a
very diverse society and there are very
different ways and sometimes
contradictory ways of life
the incompetence and the structural
corruption and the massive repression of
the
protests protesters
have cost the current regime all of its
legitimacy and its capacity for reform
in order to save Iran we need to avoid
violence we need to Foster Democratic
and peaceful Solutions
and none of that can come from outside
it has to come from within the country
and as a result of that from on the
basis of this uh we propose the idea of
a referendum being held on the fate of
the current regime if the people vote
for regime change we would then need to
put together a constituent assembly to
draft a new constitution
and then there would be another
referendum to vote on the draft
Constitution
and all of this should be done in
keeping with the rules of Equitable free
and fair elections
the current laws of the Islamic Republic
cannot be a part of this process because
they don't
ensure the rights of the various groups
of Iranian society that make the society
up
and we also need to take into account
the fact
that in order to help the Iranian people
what we need and what we're calling for
is not that people meddle in the Affairs
of Iran but that the Iranian people be
supported
that involves moral support
of the protests and demonstrations
uh support for people who are in prison
and
civil
Disobedience which is massive in Iran
that also needs to be supported it's a
very complicated situation
and the international everything the the
International Community does should take
into account various elements and not
give the Iranian regime the opportunity
to reinforce its uh repressive
activities
so what we are calling for should not
feed into
the aims or playing to the hands of the
regime
so I repeat what is very important is
we need to help Iran find its own way
from within thank you for your attention
foreign
and thanks to all our guests here who
have spoken to us who have addressed us
they very well highlighted also very
different areas of Defense of Iranian
people and different areas of necessary
change thanks to to each and and every
contribution please allow me now to give
the floor to Hara Neumann who has not
only contributed but also permanently
asked for this week of solidarity you
are the first speaker and then we will
follow our list Allah you have to flow
thank you Mr chair and well thank you
everyone who made this possible but also
who is here today to keep on going the
discussion about Iran and the revolution
that is happening there
we could see I think from all the
speakers that everyone has suffered
great losses because of the regime that
is in place in Iran and what it does to
its people most of you are not able to
go back to the country by the way nor am
I
um most of you are facing personal
attacks
um and some of you or I assume most of
you have lost friends and family members
the revolution that is happening since
three months has clearly profoundly
shaken Iran but it has I think also
shaken the world because it has shed
light on the atrocities of the regime
and of its resistance on on the people
in Iran it has also showed the big
solidarity that is inside the country
where women minorities went to the
streets but then supported by people
from all walks of life and all gender
and what this revolution has clearly
achieved is that everyone now knows how
brutal this regime is how it is beating
raping executing its own people only to
protect its power and its kleptocratic
way of life
and the only response the regime has
apparently contradictory to some
announcements that we heard here is
simply more repression
and I think that that is why it is quite
clear that the regime is impossible to
reform and that it is a big threat to
its own people to the region and to the
world as a whole
and the question many here in the
European Union we are asking ourselves
right now is
what is the alternative
and how can we get there and this is
also how I understand some of your
remarks and on the ones that is clear
that we as the European Union we have to
do our homework there are a number of
items outstanding the parliament clearly
demands for listing irgc on the
terrorist it hasn't happened yet maybe
EAS and who is here as well I can
clarify a bit on that we said we can't
negotiate a nuclear deal with the regime
while it kills its own people so this is
also clear demand from this Parliament
and we have to better protect those who
are opposing the regime with Visa but
also those who in the diaspora from
transnational threats they are attacked
here we know of many some of you can't
roam around freely in your own cities
anymore and I think this is unacceptable
and the issue of technology has been
raised especially with the internet
but there are a number of additional
aspects in the discussion and I would be
interested to hear your remarks on this
one because yes there seems to be some
kind of an understanding we want a
referendum in Iran so that the people of
Iran can decide freely where they want
to go assuming and hoping that that
would be
moving towards let's say a secular
democracy but how can we get the regime
to the referendum
that is the key question I think and we
have discussions about sending
remittances back home in a strike fund
so I would like to understand how your
position is on this one and how they you
can support this being possible how is
the gap bridge between discussions in
the diaspora and those inside the
country
and maybe the last question how can we
reach a more respectful way to have
these debates amongst each others
because at least how I observe it the
attacks are rising in in in magnitude
but also in in language and I don't
think this is helping in any way if
those who are
against the regime are attacking each
other sometimes more fiercely and in a
worse way than they are attacking the
regime and that is something I perceive
and I find this very much not helpful so
thank you all for for coming here for
bringing your different perspectives and
I'm also happy to see so many um
colleagues here joining us for the
discussion
thank you Hannah let me read out the
list of speakers which we already have
and then I would invite the colleagues
who are not on the list to give us a a
hand to give us a signal that we can
take note I have and that will be the
order of speakers as well Isabel wiesela
ties Royden one of our affid
membersun who is also our effort
standing rapporte on Iran this is the
list of speakers so far if you are not
on the list please indicate
so
uh now we see three more uh colleagues
in nature you as well
the three colleagues in front have
signaled to us uh and I appreciate that
the uh my home base the group of
socialists and Democrats is taking a
huge interest in our debate and you will
be on the list of course Isabel visila
thank you very much chair first of all
I'd like to thank all of those who have
spoken before me
we cannot talk at the moment about Iran
without expressing our emotion I won't
uh
elaborate on that any further but I'd
just like to say that we fully support
the revolution uh in Iran and those in
prison and who are suffering in other
ways
uh words fail me but what you're going
through at the moment really is terribly
that's the first point
I will be brief because I want to spend
more time listening to you than speaking
we are faced with this dilemma
as has been said
I remember the first intervention
intervention of Astana when she said
that I am afraid of
Leaping into a battle uh
and having the battle finishing as it
did last time with dead people people in
jail and without any changes and those
words still resonate
Within Me
and we're organizing our efforts now and
doing everything we can and we'll
continue to do that and to stand side by
side with you but I and I have trouble
working out what will be the most
efficient in effective in Iran uh
cutting relations as you have in part
asked so sending diplomats back to home
uh severing diplomatic ties and so forth
with Iran on the one hand and on the
other hand
trying to exert pressure through a
dialogue
without having without being seen as
weak
without being denigrated by Iran but
doing what we can as far in fostering
dialogue so I would like to hear from
you all
uh say how we deal with this dilemma
I've heard you speak
some of you are run more with one option
others more with the other but if you
could
um
talk about this dilemma and tell us
about the specific effects that each
course of action can have and that's
what it's all about helping the people
there on the ground thank you very much
Mrs Isabel
yeah thank you chair and thanks to all
our guests for your inspiration
um which is the same inspiration that we
get from the brave Iranian people
um uh continuing their Uprising and as I
said many times before they will not
give up I'm convinced that they will not
give up
but we also must not give up right
and it's it's actually begins begins to
become uh irritating The Silence from
the member states and from the council
after our numerous calls to list the
irgc for what they are
a terrorist regime and
um we filed the first amendment in the
common foreign security policy in
January uh to to list them and we had
several calls after that so
um I there's not a question to you
because that's our job but um it it is
the same the same challenge
I was invited by an Iranian friend in
the Netherlands to a festival in front
of Azadi Tower where we will dance
without risking to be arrested where we
will celebrate freedom and that will
happen I'm convinced that they will come
but the question is how do we get there
how can we overcome and that's a
question to you how can we overcome this
next phase as I call it because now
people are especially here not in Iran
but especially here losing the faith a
little bit so how can we come to that
next phase how can we combat the
division because division is the
greatest gift to any autocrat
and um I want to ask you
um hey you also said Miss Goro that we
need to uh focus on the Iranians the
Iranians in Iran so how can we
get rid of that debate that is starting
now outside Iran among Iranian diraspora
among their supporters that are trying
to take sides that is the worst thing I
think that can uh can can happen to us
that we become divided that we start to
focus on discussions in New York in in
Amsterdam in in Paris instead of
focusing on Iran and my second question
I I think to to anyone who wants to
answer it how can we help you
individually in that struggle in that uh
struggle to keep our eyes on the ball
and uh and how can we contribute to that
Unity as a parliament as a family of of
European parliaments who are also
convinced that we need to do more the
the the uh it's more at the level of the
member states and the commission that is
now stuck but um I would be grateful for
your answers and thanking you again for
your inspiration thanks
thank you uh Tyson benna is our next
speaker first vice president of our
subcommittee planner you have to follow
Mercy president thank you chair I would
like to ask Mrs Mr ajamant
on what basis
on the basis of what political analysis
of the situation in Iran
Mr masavi decided publicly to break
with the regime on what basis so that's
my first question my second question
is
is the division that we have seen
mounting over the past 15 years within
the Iranian clergy
to what extent has that increased
following the demonstrations and the
upheavals that we've seen of recent
times thank you
foreign
thank you chair first of all
I'd like to thank the four uh speakers
and express our solidarity and uh
admiration for those who are working
tirelessly within Iran and outside Iran
I was in Tehran at alamco and the
dalavant the two highest mountains in
Iraq
uh and I was uh there I was in Vienna uh
when there were demonstrations in front
of the UN building in Vienna and
the total surveillance that we have in
Iran
uh Breeze fear
in a rainy into the hearts of Iranians
who
are living in Europe they are afraid of
persecution in spite of the fact that
they live in the European Union
secondly I also thankful that the
situation of the Kurds was mentioned
here
the fascinating thing here
is that this affects all sectors of
society all uh cultural groups all ages
the people as a whole are suffering as a
result of all of this two further points
now
we need to repeat our call for the
Revolutionary guard to go on to the
terrorist list
that's the first thing and second thing
is my question to all people have joined
us here today what else can we do where
can we increase our sanctions how can we
support you further in this uh important
times
is our next speaker
yes thank you so much welcome to the
European Parliament and uh let me first
start by expressing my full solidarity
with all your political struggles and
also with your personal situation
sinking into account that you are on the
prosecution by uh by a regime that
denies a fundamental freedoms so let me
start by by expressing my my full
solidarity to all of you and thank you
again for being with with us I have
three questions very briefly the first
one I think it would be good if you
could elaborate a bit more on how do you
see the the evolution of the process
protest inside the country it seems that
that the regime wants to show to the
outside world that the situation has
come down but we also have reports and
we see more and more women were doing
actions against the hijab so I would
like
um to know your views on how do you
think this will evolve uh in the next uh
in the next month thinking also into
account that we are entering the the
um the the summer and that can have of
course consequences on all that secondly
um also Hannah Neumann made the question
which I think is very relevant for us as
well is how to make uh or how to help
the work of the diaspora and the people
on the ground be more unite or work
better or stronger I have the impression
that there are strong debates a bit
around that and I think it would be good
also to to see your views on also the
role that the EP can play on that I mean
this this week of solidarities goes of
course into that direction but I think
it would be good to know your
Reflections on that and thirdly again to
go back to the most difficult point of
course which is
how to settle the EU position towards
the regime today because on the one hand
if we want to have leverage and an
influence in order to stop executions
and stop repression we need to keep some
level of channels open with the regime
on the other hand we know that that we
cannot as far as for instance are going
to resume and close the nuclear deal at
the moment with the situation at the
moment but where where does the balance
lie I think it would be important also
to hear your opinions and then in that
debate I think one cannot ignore the
recent developments with with China and
Saudi Arabia so how this new Regional
Dynamics uh do you think should
influence the position of the EU in
relation to Iran because this cannot be
ignored of course so what are those are
Mastery questions and thank you again
for being with us
thank you Ernest next speaker Rafael
kluxman
Mercy chair is thank you very much chair
and thank you very much to our guests
for their courageous message that
they're bringing to our Parliament my
first question is not for our guests
it's for the eeas and the whole of the
council
how come
the uh Islamic revolutionary court guard
court has still not found its way onto
the list of terrorist organizations how
is it not recognized as a terrorist
organization not only do they a wield
Terror on the Iranian people but they
commit terrorist acts so how you know
even on our
European soil
why has this not happened how has this
not happened what is stopping the irgc
being classified as a terrorist
organization secondly a question to you
all
looking at all of the political
prisoners currently
uh by the regime what measures are we
adopting are these public campaigns
working uh does it put families in
danger and does it or rather does it
allow it to shine a light onto this and
get them freed what can we do
specifically to help people who are
currently languishing in the Jails of
the Iranian regime thirdly to Mr
ismailian you have mentioned strikes
and possible solidarity funds could you
perhaps fill us in more on that uh what
uh relations uh do the trade unions we
ran have with the etuc European trade
Union Congress and uh if we set up uh
solidarity funds how can we be sure that
the money actually does make its way to
the people who really are uh fighting
the good fight on the ground
uh we look at Industries
uh uh
the uh a fact that uh the uh the trade
unions are are calling these strikes is
that perhaps a way to really bring down
the economy thank you Rafael hi Sandra
Moretti thank you very much thank you
chair and uh thank you Donna for uh
Hannah rather for uh promoting this and
all the speakers uh and reporters who
really have spoken and are a source of
inspiration to us all today is the 25th
of April I'm Italian in Italy today we
celebrate uh the liberation of our
country from the German Nazis today in
Italy we remember all the activists uh
the partisans of the resistance the uh
partisans uh
who in a certain way rebelled against
the regime and a left uh their families
left the university embraced their
weapons to combat uh the uh Invaders and
thanks to the resistance today we have
uh uh one of the most beautiful uh
Italian uh uh uh constitutions so I'd
like to thank you all for being here
because I really hope that your courage
and the resistance that you have been
showing over the last few months in Iran
really can be the source of a huge
liberal Revolution to liberate this
marvelous country of yours to have
freedom dignity and bring those to all
over these months uh we among all of our
colleagues have been trying to give you
support to do whatever we can
so that uh your voices can be heard and
not be isolated to to Really amplify
that in this chamber which is a symbol
of freedom and a justice so I take on
board that all of the requests that the
colleagues have made to you how can we
help you even more particularly
also I am very concerned for all the
detainees for the conditions of people
in jails and uh of course how they are
being treated how the people who who
survive uh this torture
we have uh uh taken uh on board the uh a
sponsorship of these 13 that he needs is
this useful we want to continue
to get more and more MEPS are on board
for this kind of political adoption if
you like of these uh prisoners putting a
stop to contracts and Commercial
agreements with the regime to to
isolate Iran is that effective is that
efficient or as has been said is that in
fact just punishing the people of Iran
is that negative I extremely uh I find
it very indignant that the irgc has not
been included on the list of terrorist
organizations worldwide and uh
visas for activists uh is this something
that can be a useful tool and if so how
do you think
um Europe is uh really performing on
this level thank you very much
um
thank you very much chair and thank you
for having you with us and it is really
great to have the opportunity to share
your views and your statement
shows clearly that the European Union
must support the Revolutionary forces
that Iran will find its own way for its
Democratic Society I would like to raise
the following question last week the
very controversial raila palavi beta
historic visit to Israel apparently the
Iranian opposition has different views
on this some say it reinforces their
position that Israel is not an enemy
While others say it does not help the
protest movement
second question is for month the cases
of poisoning in schools have caused
Great Horror apparently not a day goes
by without the text
that's why Ms Amnesty International has
called for an independent and
comprehensive investigation what else do
you think needs to happen my last
question is
we can see that girth and women in Iran
are on the streets without their hearts
head head scarves and the regime is
reacting with more repression on this
development last week the government
declared that it would take drastic
action against anyone who disregards the
head scarf law it immediately followed
up its word with action they closed a
lot of companies they closed a lot of
restaurants at the University students
protesters against these measures
and this shows clearly the regime is not
willing to make any confession this time
it's excess excess existential survival
is at stake
which is wide places to fight against
dissolent women or above all other
burning issues how do you assess this
thank you
did I miss anybody who would like to
speak from our colleagues here in the
room this is not the case then I will
now give the opportunity for our guests
for our distinguished panelists to
answer
dear friends you have seen the huge
commitment of our colleagues to be
supportive there have been very general
questions on the development in Iran but
also very specific questions directed to
you and to your inputs I would do that
in the reverse order and first gift of
law to adeshia Amir
ayoman to address us please you have the
flop
foreign
thank you very much for your questions
well what's how can we change
people's lives
or what to change my life well it's it's
not something that uh happened uh
suddenly
they've had a very
position affirm positions in 2017 and
2019 that was re-confirmed with the
repression
and the show uh
you know the repression has uh really
very much increased as there has been a
request for self-determination so the
the main lines really that are important
uh in the development of the situation
we run uh they they affect his position
if you look at the breadth of the
protests against the regime uh you can
see there's a correlation with the
breadth of the repression the situation
shows that people have already sort of
outgrown the uh current uh
regime that the regime no longer
respects any rules of democracy you can
see that in their response so there's no
legitimacy anymore for this regime
added to that is the social injustice
economic issues the great crisis
across the country
which it is currently facing
and it underscores uh the most important
crisis so which is the Paradox the
insolvable Paradox of the regime
there's a there's an internal Paradox in
the regime
in the Faria as I see
uh
you've got a dictatorial regime which is
a personal and irresponsible
personal region which cannot respond to
the demands and requirements of the
Iranian people he says you just have to
keep just pushing forward so that well
we've been calling for the uh in the
overall the total application of the
Constitution for many years
and uh
to uh have a a sort of uh a transfer uh
or a movement to a a different Society
you have to overcome a number of these
issues but this is it has to be based on
the rule of law
so
this is uh what I would say that needs
to happen for the future of Iran
I think they were already differences
inside the uh GC
these differences have grown
considerably
uh over the last few years because a lot
of Iranians are no longer uh satisfied
or no longer agree with the way that the
country is being run but they don't have
the resources they don't have the means
to overthrow the regime
how many in the last 30 years has tried
to change the very basis
of uh Society the ecological basis
Society
having the clergy depend upon the regime
and that's a very in important in our
analysis the current situation he's
created this dependence on him by the
clergy
because they know that the respect of uh
Islam and uh and the Shiite movement is
Central
uh to uh his uh um power but of course
so that runs counter to the very
fundamental principles
of uh the Shiite uh movement uh I have
should I address the other questions
made or should I stop here okay I'll
carry on
other questions you've asked the
question about the situation of women in
Iran I think uh where Civil Society
really has uh really been successful is
the uh Civil Disobedience
um it's the first time in fact that the
regime has actually been publicly
um
I've beaten it's uh lost its legitimacy
it's shown it's incompetence in running
the country
if the regime
Falls
for what we're seeing is that women have
pushed forward this uh to a certain
extent successful uh unveiling of the
regime
but it's a very complicated situation
because even within the repressive
forces and the police force
they're not prepared to follow uh the
orders of their superiors they've got
daughters they've got wives who are
behaving like these protesters and while
making the collaborations and
conversations they've had with Harmony
they have spoken to how many
we have the same issue happening inside
our houses
so they really can't do anything to to
stop the women so the Declarations
they've really insisted upon this fact
that the important thing
is uh you know to uh the the future of
the Republic depends on the on the women
fighting for this
it's a very specific question of are you
satisfied with that or would you come
back Banner just
just let me clarify one thing when you
say that women won the battle are you
alluding to the fact that now we see
women walking without a headscarf in the
streets of Tehran or are you referring
to something else
no I'm actually referring to something
else
they have partially won this combat
because
you know fortunately they can now walk
in the streets without uh headscarf but
also the uh the the Iranian repression
will not
prevail
they've partially won because this is
Unstoppable now
because it shows that the regime has
already lost their battle
despite all of the restrictions they've
imposed they will not win the day
and the mechanisms that they've tried to
create
to uh sort of
bring women once again under their heel
and to stop the resistance is not
working
and this is also visible within the
internal player forces within the regime
me to answer the questions
what
well just about the issue of women for
me it's also a victory and I'll tell you
why because
it's a not just uh being able to walk
bareheaded in the street it's everything
gets the question of the available
headscarf that's part of the ideology of
the regime up to now we've had a lot of
movements and lots of demonstrations but
each time we said
it's the fault of this or that
government but now
because we were never bold enough to say
that the target is uh Harmony is the in
the Islamic Republic but now thanks to
this question of headscar sounds this
question of women it's the we can see
the end of the uh Islamic Republic for
the perhaps for the time being the
movement uh
uh has been oppressed and is being
oppressed but the important thing is the
change of mentality in Iranian we've
changed everything we've said okay up to
now we've put a lot of resources into
trying to reform the regime but that's
it
now with this whole headscarf issue say
we are demanding the end of the Islamic
Republic we uh
uh want to have politicians that set up
true gender parity and gender equality
throughout the the green movement of the
other demonstrations uh the question the
women's issue was always marginalized
but now for the first time they've
accepted that this issue is fundamental
it's front and center of the whole
movement many women have taken part in
these demonstrations and they had other
claims and other demands Kurdish from
involution or women and classic
questions and National issues minorities
ethnic minorities and so on
because oppression is not quite the same
but uh what has been important and what
we've seen here now is that they've
really attacked the very foundations of
the regime for the first time the
Islamic Republic
you know they've put down the
demonstrations but now they for uh
focusing uh and targeting girls at
school saying well up to now you've made
a lot of progress but now I'm going to
pull you out of school so that you can't
uh learn just like the Taliban are doing
in Afghanistan and for me this time we
see that the regime that they are afraid
of the movement and there's no going
back there's a lot of changes happening
in Iranian society and we said okay
we've got this and that and that demand
we've marginalized so many things like
women and ethnic minorities but now for
us that's it uh
our demands are something we're
insisting on we're insisting on women's
rights and we need and we absolutely
have to achieve our rights and it's a
victory because it's changed the
Dynamics in society and the government
know they cannot continue in this vein
thank you Fatima how many million
respond to questions
thank you very much there were a number
of questions so I tried to answer a few
of them so uh the point is that the main
question was how we can help
I mean the most uh efficient way is to
empower Iranian people inside the
country and there are ways to do that I
can I can focus on three things uh one
is internet as we said several times the
access to Internet is blocked in several
in various places in the country two
main issues in Internet one is a star
link and the other one is VPN so uh
people need VPN to have an access to to
the social media applications and also
astar link for the activist for uh for
for ordinary people
I don't mean that this doesn't happen
there are lots of Iranians the Young
Generation out of the country that
they're already
started that and uh I'm in touch with uh
a lot of people like as I said the young
activists around the world that we are
focusing on this and we are we're trying
to organize and have a way to send a
starling inside the country and also
vpns the other thing is helping the
families of detainees and families of
the
um I mean all the individuals that we
lost in the last six months or in the
last 40 years
so uh one important thing is that you
probably see that some detainees got
released on bail or other situations but
there are more than 100 prominent
activists that
they never let them go like I heard
National Institute as name for example
so she's out on medical conditions but
they wanted to take her husband inside
the prison so another activists I know
that another activist like had has a
trial this week so the prominent ones
they never get released so they are the
ones that they can plan for for the next
steps and when we talk about negotiation
or when we talk about this uh political
channels that I try to address that to I
mean it's very important to ask the
regime to uh like uh release this 100
150 prominent activists then you will
see the change then you will see the
change and the third one is about the
strikes
I know that some some Iranians out of
the country they're already started to
work on the strike funds but it's very
difficult they're
very important issues here the first one
is that we need an exemption
I think it's very difficult to send
money to Iran it's impossible actually
in in larger amounts and uh for a
starlink we got the exemption so that's
why their styling goes inside the
country but for struck funds not yet so
we need the exemption from different
countries first and we need to add you
know a point some ngos that they can
send the funds I'm not worried about the
networks inside the country they are
networks inside the country that they
can work together and find the right
people to to distribute the money the
most important part and the most
difficult one is out of the country the
exemptions and the way that we can send
money legally to the country they are
underground ways but
to to send legal money there it's a
little difficult we're working on that
too for example I I mean
um communication with Canadian
government to appoint to find one two
ngos that we can raise money send it to
Iran not only for strikes for for
internet for vpns and uh also and about
the the negotiation with Iran and the
embassies you know
44 years of crimes
44 years and we have seen that the
embassies have been open for a long time
when I'm saying that the ambassadors
should be called back
because I haven't seen any outcome of
the negotiation
so in 1980s they executed thousands of
people but the embassies were open
in 1990s they oppressed the student
movement and the the embassies were open
but the time that you called the
ambassadors after Mykonos
uh terrorism attack in Berlin
you saw that the reform happened in Iran
months later
so that the only language they
understand is the political pressure so
if you don't send them the very strong
political message they don't get it they
don't understand it and okay and after
that the embassies were open again in
2019 nine they oppressed the green
movement
and then the blood in November and then
the shutdown the the airplane and after
that now you see that in the last seven
months they hang people in sham trials
and their embassies are open do you see
any changes and most of these victims
are children
most of them in blood in November they
killed more than 50 children in in in
flight ps752 they murdered 29 children
and in in the last six months more than
70 of the victims were children and the
embassies are open I we don't see any
changes so that's why we asked for for
some a strong message to the Islamic
Republic of Iran and about the Visas
that you ask yes we need visas for some
victims we have a boy in Turkey right
now he's 18 year old zany Orton bro he
lost his one eye and he's losing another
eye a family of six the community out of
Iran like in Canada we respond we
sponsor them we say okay if they come to
Canada or other countries we'll sponsor
them we take them to the hospitals but
this Visa issues is like an obstacle for
us and this boy is suffering he was in
Camp for for days for weeks and now he's
out of the camp and some Iranians there
they're taking care of them but Germany
gives visa to two of the family members
it's a family of six so this moment that
they have four children one last eye the
other two are 13 and the the fourth one
is seven year old what do you want them
to do just leave two of them or three of
them there in turkey and go move to
Germany no that's that's not fair
so we need to see these issues and look
at the human rights in a right way so
visas yes and this isn't zanyar is just
an example of dozens of people in turkey
that they're suffering and other just
examples of of the suffering of the
Iranian people thank you very much
many thanks for this very concrete
contribution before I give the floor to
madigo or let me also invite you as well
as our other guests not to leave without
giving us that very concrete information
where we can be supportive also in
respect of activities in Our member
states I think my members here in this
subcommittee have all shown with their
contributions that they are standing
ready to support you also in individual
cases whenever they can do so so please
give us more concrete
information and and perhaps we can via
your support also become active here in
these cases you mentioned
I appreciate your attention to the
details in my country and
I try to answer to all questions but in
one or two sentence
uh Islamic regime tried to pass some
rules against women and the strategy was
that when we passed the rules against
women men support us
when we passed the rules against Kurdish
people or Turkish people first people
support us
or if the official religion be Islam and
Shia the sheer people support us but now
especially during uh five or six or I
can say in the late the decades
people support each other without
attention to the gender to the religion
to the ethnicity and it's very very
important because it's break down the
strategy of regime for make an enemy
from people against each other so that's
why the this this Revolution and this
movement is completely different with
the past movement previous movement
another thing is about
um
a dialogue
uh yes dialogue is good but when a woman
from Western Country who believed to the
other religion and don't live to the
Islam go to Iran and in front of the
more love your hijab it's not
negotiation it's not dialogue
it's a really
when we as a women see this kind of
photo or movie just we think how they
can't understand we as a women under
dictatorship under Islamic regime
just I as a women
begging please all the women who doesn't
believe to the Islam don't wear hijab in
front of the mullah in Iran it's not
negotiation
really bother us
and but you say we want to make a
negotiation
I can't understand it
and another thing about the
um
how can help to Iranian in diaspora
ignore the propaganda regimes
don't talk with the propaganda regime
the journalists
who who are not just Iranian journalists
the Islamic propaganda support with the
oil money
and can change the truth
if you want to believe the propaganda
you think all the people in Iran live in
peace and all of them love mullah
according to the propaganda it's the
facts
and all the time in the Islamic
Television TV everybody say all over the
world or all over the world in rest of
the world is war and all the men raped
the women
and
all the country are live in the poverty
and the best place is Iran
and that's why we need the
freedom and internet
and that's why you shouldn't talk about
the free Rhythm just uh
with uh without pay attention to the
human rights in Iran
and another thing is about the
connection between Iran Islamic regime
and Saudi Arabia and China
I think I believe the modern Revolution
women life freedom
is a danger big danger for all the
extremists regime in Middle East of
course Saudi Arabia should support the
Iran because if women can break all the
Islamic rules
other women in other countries Middle
East Iraq
Egypt Syria
and Saudi Arabia believe okay we can be
equal
and it can make a feminist revolution in
the Middle East
so I I think the Saudi Arabia
have to support the Islamic regime
not the secular government in Iran and
about Russia and China
when
the
government in Iran can support by money
and buy a product from China so it's
good for Chinese governments and when
the Islamic regime doesn't have any
connection and relationship with the
Western Country it's uh it's the best
situation for Chinese and for Russia so
I think it's until that day that the
Iranian regime doesn't have connection
with the Western Country
Russia and China become a good friend
for the regime
and about the future in Iran uh I think
when the human rights activates all over
the world
think about the Franco Hitler Mussolini
or others doesn't think they want to
back to the monarchy people in this kind
of country want to back to the monarchy
or want the republic governments
uh so it's the same for Iran after going
out to Harmony and after uh revolution
in Iran people in the independent and
freedom referendum can say what they
want so before that you as a Western
Country out of Iran just should support
the people for that days after that
people in Iran can make a decision what
they want they want democracy but the
constitutional monarchy or the secular
Republican
and so the after that it's um
just the people in Iran business
and uh
last thing about the student activists
Islamic religion prefer to close the
University
especially during last months
but uh the students activists make a
protest make demonstration in the
University they was arrested and but
they still make a demonstration and
sitting in the University
so it's it's very important we attention
to the human rights and education rights
as a part of Human Rights women love as
a part part of Human Rights and uh
yes I think that's enough thank you
thanks very much
thanks very much all our guests we have
the pleasure to have with us
Deputy head of division Iran of the
European external Action Service
um for comments and remarks we have seen
how important
European institutions are for defining
our relationship in this situation with
the people of Iran that means member
states that means the high rep that
means our European external Action
Service could you please come in for
your comments
thank you very much chairman Bowman and
Frau Ernst hundred members of the
parliament and their guests in the
speaking capacity and really thank you
for facilitating the exchange today it
just Builds on the Intensive political
attention that you had over the last
month's on Iran uh on including the
serious human rights violation
um
I think is is not uh uh you to say that
after the Dreadful killing of uh
masamini uh and the Eastern protest uh
we had a very Swift and very forceful
reaction as a u
H we not only reacted publicly with
clear messages in support of the Iranian
people uh we um we passed statements
Declaration of the high representative
on behalf of your 27 member states we
had interventions including in a
parliament uh here or a high
representative in the in the wider
plenary of the parliament
and I think uh there was no occasion
that high rep didn't use to really pass
very very very strong messages to his
counterpart in Iran uh uh on on
everything that happened over the last
months uh and uh and I think uh the
Iranian authorities know very very
clearly where we stand and we clear the
ground I would say very firmly
um
in he's the best as chairman of the
Foreign Affairs Council over the last
six months the Foreign Affairs Council
had Iran on its agenda constantly either
on the current affairs or a discussion
point and
um it was under the term of the high
representative that we adopted not less
than seven packages of sanctions on on
serious human rights violation in Iran
and the last one was even yesterday at
FSC in Luxembourg and we now have more
or less uh 238 entries on the Iran human
rights regime and this is now more than
double the number compared to before uh
the protests started
um
some of you mentioned the issue of
listing irdc's terrorist organization
and I think you know very well uh of how
annoyman and uh and uh
maps that raised the issue that this
issue is in the hands of the member
states you need unanimous decision by
member states and you need to have clear
uh legal hurdles being passed
and uh we have irgc being listed as uh
in its entirety we have irgc individuals
and entities which are being listed
under different human different uh
Central regime under the EU Central
regime but on this particular one you
know very well the discussion is between
member states and based on on this two
clear uh criteria first in political
anonymity and second uh legal hurdles to
be to be passed
um speaking about the member states and
the council
in December we had a new set of constant
conclusions on Iran and I it was uh
compared to the the conclusions that we
had uh back in January 2019 it was a
very different tone uh and I really
invited to to go through through the
latest set of conclusions and the tone
is very very tough uh including on all
the issues that we have in relation to
Iran including on all the human rights
violation that we uh we we have under
our attention today
um
at the same time
um and I'm glad that some of you
mentioned uh
the question to what extent you balance
the overall pressure with the need to
have dialogue and that's precisely what
is the the gist of the conclusions that
we had and that's precisely what member
states also Advocate to keep this
balance between between pressure and
dialogue because precise of his dialogue
allows us to to Really uh address all
the issues that are of serious concern
to us including the the human rights
violation including the Consular issues
and the arbitrary Detention of EU
citizens in Iran
um and uh not to mention uh all the the
other issues and with a weaker
cooperation with Iran which is already
happening uh in the bilateral level
comes certainly a weaker access to to
voices and people in Iran and to
humanize the vendors and that's
unfortunately the case but it's a way to
also uh to to pass a very clear message
to the same time to the arena
authorities that we cannot have just
business as usual
and that's why I think it's important
that you you are here today as as many
of your uh country fellows and and share
with us how you see the situation and
and how
um the European Parliament or the
institution overall can be of of help
thank you so much
thank you for your contribution uh Mr
Nita could I come back with
one precise question and with one idea
um first of all you mentioned the
technical hurdles of putting the
Revolutionary guards on this terrorists
is there also an argument a political
argument on content which is present in
the deliberations of the council members
are in the uh
environment of the high rep which could
be discussed here
and would you also accept that we
continue this conversation which we had
today perhaps I will discuss with the
coordinators during the afternoon either
in a public meeting or in a in camera
meeting to show us the concrete list of
activities of support member states as
well as the European institutions
are already and to hopefully tomorrow uh
increasingly
um addressing to uh the freedom fighters
in Iran that would be my question but I
see Rafael cooksman as well uh
interesting in taking the floor and I
see Hana Neumann interesting we have
some minutes left so perhaps we should
do that exercise very quickly Rafael and
then yeah I will be very brief thank you
chair just uh for us to to understand we
know perfectly well that it's not your
decision and it's not the high right
decision but for us to understand a bit
more about why our common requests from
the parliament is not followed up by
action and is the same on Wagner for
instance group
could you tell us which countries which
member states are blocking because it's
always the same Prime with the council
that it's dark
there is no publicity about the debates
and therefore you don't have actions
taken and nobody is assuming any cost
for inaction
so could you please tell us
in which way and with which arguments
which countries are blocking
thank you Anna
thank you my question adds a bit a bit
one a first on the issue of dialogue we
know that if you have dialogue with
someone it kind of means to at least
recognize that they have some power and
they speak for some people so having
dialogue with the regime stabilizes the
regime in this position so my question
is what is it that we got in return over
the last six months and at the same time
do you also have dialogue with other
people
such as these six up here but also
others that are out there to also
understand what their perspective on
Iran is how is that happening in which
context because I'm only aware about the
dialogue that Eis is having with um
representatives of the regime and the
second question goes with the terror
listing and Raphael mentioned one point
so which are the memory states that are
actually blocking because we in our
capacities can pressure our own
governments because there is anonymity
almost inside the European Parliament
for the listing so which member states
are blocking and we know that on some
topics EAS is hiding behind member
states I have the impression that is the
case here on some topics especially our
high rep can be quite outspoken and can
be quite provocative in pushing member
states in a direction I have not
observed this when it comes to the
listing on behalf of Mr Burrell correct
me please if I'm wrong and tell me where
he did that and the last last question
and maybe that's more something for
later in camera meeting
we when we see where EU support goes
also financially inside Iran I don't see
so much support going to Civil Society
organization maybe we can discuss
internally how this could be improved
also with some of the information that
we can also get internally from UI
because I know once you talk about it it
gets a more complicated and maybe Udo if
one of the speakers also has a question
to yeah yes I if the time allows I think
that would be interesting
um to make give them the opportunity as
well I take this in the slim version
that in the extensive version I take
this
proposal in part if there is any
question from our guests to the external
Action Service I asked them now to raise
their hand this is not the case so Mr
Nita please come back to the questions
of our colleagues
thank you very much for the questions
um just to start with the the irgc
listing um
you know very well that I'm not in a
position to share the names of my member
states the discussion in the Foreign
Affairs Council are confidential and
that's the way it is so it's it's beyond
my mandate or the Mandate of es to share
the names of member states
and how the discussion goes in the
console this is just by the way of
procedures uh we are not in a position
to share such information uh at all
second in terms of dialogue and what we
have achieved so far
I mean we have we have been uh I think
over the last month has been very clear
in in the bilateral engagement with the
the Iranian authorities and pass very
very strong messages and I think that's
precisely what this let's say the
channels of dialogue managed to do uh is
to really uh make sure that they really
understand where we are and our red
lines and uh and that these have to be
understood
um you mentioned the chairman Billman
about the extent to which uh
the political consideration in rgc
listing have been taken into account and
I think it's very clear for everyone
sanctions EU sanctions at all are first
and foremost a political message
there is a wider debate to an extent
sanctions are effective or not
but the first foremost is a political
message and I think it was very
important and is still very important
that we have his sanctions and we member
states have been very clear in the
conclusions uh of December that we stand
ready to uh they stand ready to to uh to
uh to look at all the options at their
disposal including restrictive measures
in approaching and addressing all the
issues of concern if you're on and I
think that's very very strong message
that member states have put very loudly
in the public and certainly every single
decision uh including on on sanctions is
a political decision and uh the legal
herd is that I mentioned and as I said
is is something that is is in the
remnant of the of the foreign First
Council and with the member states uh
and their confidential uh discussion on
this uh that something which is again
um a combination between political and
legal and I think uh it's Sovereign
decision that every single member State
how its position itself on this issue
thank you any thanks Mr Anita for being
with us today and many thanks for this
uh dialogue and this conversation as the
chairman of the subcommittee of Human
Rights let me conclude on this element
of our conversation first of all uh we
very well understand your personal
situation and that you cannot go in this
dialogue beyond your means that is on an
individual basis totally justified and
accepted but for us this is not and that
has nothing to do with you personal that
is not acceptable on institutional terms
because neither the subcommittee no
offered
co-organizer today not the delegation
for Iran not the European Parliament is
willing to fall victim to the Kafka
syndrome
sitting in front of the palace and do
not find how to act access a system
which is a democratic institution under
the European treaties and we will find
our way to get access I'm pretty sure
and I think I can speak on behalf of all
of my colleagues here we will find our
way to open this dialogue we will find
our way to get access to this
information we are requesting and we are
finding our way to send messages now the
floor is to Cornelia as the head of the
Iran delegation and she will find her
personal resume as well perhaps also
indicate the forthcoming issues
thanks a lot
I'd like to say the following
first of all thank you
to one and all
and the position that's being taken is
not an easy position to take
and it's been taken very judiciously
colleagues please look at what the
impact would be of such a terror listing
most of these measures are already in
place
access to data
the whole
issue about assets
that's been in place for a long time now
then there's the question of the
definition of Terror
and what is we need to be very clear
about how that's defined what that means
and their clear
opportunities for the regime what would
happen if the regime were to challenge a
terror listing and the difficulties that
would pose
it's a daily battle
to find the right answers to the issues
it's not an easy task
I think it'd be good to find it
finding a North Korean solution is may
not be the way to go we need to be very
careful in our selection of strategy
there are no Simple Solutions I
understand all of the criticisms that
are being voiced
and I don't see any Clear Solutions uh
here and that is why we need to discuss
what has been said by the panelists we
need to talk about for example the issue
of free access to Internet and we should
try to work with the Libre committee see
if we can organize a meeting on that and
then find out how to move forward on the
basis of that we have the chaos Computer
Club in Germany for example these are X
they are experts in this sort of issue
I mean to speak with them uh and others
that is something we really need to do
then there's the financial aspect we
need the commission
how do we want to do that how do how can
we support people in a run
how can we support them if we don't have
access to uh ability if we caffeine our
ability to send money there
we need to talk about that problem as
well
support of the families of those in
prison
access to prisons that's extremely
important to the people affected by that
I've heard of initiatives from
organizations saying what can we do to
cooperate what initiatives can we launch
so we need an exchange of views here
first and foremost in order to support
the people in Iran
because that's where the power needs to
come from the people in Iran and so we
need to support them in every way we can
we need to support workers
students
so we should maybe involve the ample
committee the employment committee
they might be able to play a useful role
in all of this I think I'll get in touch
with them but we have a lot to do a lot
of work with forests and I'd like to
thank everybody at the uh leader uh the
leadership of the
Droid committee as well I'd like to
thank you all morning colleagues I think
I can speak on all of you on behalf of
all of you we are all in many many
meetings in this house in many many
assemblies delegations committee
meetings and sometimes we ask ourselves
what the real outcome was and whether it
was worthwhile to attend for this
morning I can say this was meaningful
this Gathering was meaningful thanks
again for your inputs because you made
that you gave us the chance to exchange
and you were a source of inspiration you
were a source of Hope and you laid the
ground for forthcoming support and
collaboration many many things many
ideas for these weeks for the
forthcoming events and for further
collaboration as Cornelia outlined
we have now a break and will continue at
2 30. thanks a lot